[Aplausos]
[Música]
es posible que estés pensando que de un
tiempo a esta parte en visual políti que
estamos hablando una barbaridad de
argentina pero por favor que no hace
falta razón hemos hecho un montón de
vídeos sobre el país del tango pero qué
queréis que os diga argentinas un país
súper interesante al fin y al cabo
sabeis decirme algún otro país que
durante las últimas seis décadas de
media haya tenido que negociar un
rescate con el fm y cada cuatro años y
medio porque creyeron que podían hacer
cualquier cosa y finalmente terminan
pasándose de vueltas en las decisiones
que toman argentinas se ha convertido
casi en un sinónimo de crisis de
vientres argentinas en el país de las
crisis lunes 12 de agosto de 2019
argentina sufre el segundo mayor colapso
de cualquier mercado de valores desde
1950 y la nación está nuevamente al
borde de una crisis financiera se da
vuelta a todo las empresas bajan entre
el 30 y el 50 por ciento rico país subió
350 puntos en una hora
el dólar subió lo que subió demuestra
que hay un problema grave amigos os de
mi palabra durante toda mi vida no
recuerdo una sola época donde la
actualidad argentina no estuviera
marcada por los problemas económicos
la hiperinflación de finales de los 80
el default el corralito de principios de
siglo o el colapso económico que el país
está viviendo desde el año 2015 y que le
ha obligado a negociar otra vez con el
fmi en esta ocasión un rescate de ni más
ni menos que 56 mil millones de dólares
si habéis escuchado bien 56 mil millones
de dólares evidentemente tener tantos
problemas económicos tiene consecuencias
durante los últimos 100 años argentina
ha pasado de ser uno de los 10 países
más ricos del planeta en términos per
cápita a situarse en la posición 64 esto
es al nivel de belo rusia türkmenistán o
irán
y lo peor de todo no es eso es que no
deja de caer en este ranking pero amigos
durante los últimos años un sueño ha
recorrido argentina y con él la
esperanza de que los problemas puedan
quedar de una vez por todas atrás en el
siglo 19 la lana fue el motor de
argentina a comienzos del pasado siglo
la carne la famosa carne argentina a
mediados del siglo 20 el trigo y ahora
muchos sueñan con que el gas y el
petróleo puedan cambiar la suerte del
país y esta esperanza tiene un nombre
propio vaca muerta atentos e inversiones
30 nutre si las inversiones que están
haciendo las están haciendo en vaca
muerta es increíble
vaca muerta el último tesoro
[Música]
qué le vamos a hacer no tiene el nombre
más bonito ni el más romántico pero tras
esta denominación se encuentra uno de
los grandes tesoros de la argentina pero
un momento qué diantres es eso de vaca
muerta esta es la pregunta que creo que
tenemos que hacernos antes de nada
vaca muerta amigos es una formación
geológica que tiene la capacidad de
convertir a este país a argentina en
toda una potencia exportadora de gas
situada en el borde occidental de la
patagonia argentina cerca de los andes'
y en mitad de una estepa árida y
solitaria vaca muerta es la auténtica
protagonista de noticias como esta vaca
muerta la producción de gas de junio fue
la más alta en 11 años el mes pasado se
produjo un total de 140 millones de
metros cúbicos por día lo que significó
un crecimiento interanual del 58 por
ciento es la mayor producción de gas en
11 años
ojo porque no estamos ante un
descubrimiento que podamos decir que es
estrictamente nuevo el yacimiento de
vaca muerta fue hallado por el geólogo
estadounidense charles weaver ni más ni
menos que en el año 1931 sin embargo
hasta hace relativamente muy poco no ha
sido posible hacer nada con el vaca
muerta amigos es un yacimiento de
hidrocarburos no convencionales es decir
de shell oil cuando se extrae petróleo
es el gas cuando se extrae gas
[Música]
pues bien el caso es que en este lugar
los hidrocarburos se encuentran
repartidos a lo largo y ancho de una
superficie de 30.000 kilómetros
cuadrados una superficie equivalente a
dos veces el tamaño de kuwait sólo hay
un problema a diferencia de lo que
ocurre en oriente medio aquí no basta
con pinchar el suelo para que brote el
petróleo o el gas porque aquí en vaca
muerta todos estos recursos los
hidrocarburos que están a unos 3.000
metros de profundidad
vaya y esperad porque ahí no
terminan los problemas hay otro
inconveniente aún peor en este caso del
petróleo y el gas están confinados
dentro de rocas así que para poder
explotarlos hay que construir un pozo y
a través de él inyectar una sustancia a
presión que permita fracturar esas rocas
para que el petróleo y el gas puedan
emerger por el mismo pozo es una
cuestión de presión cuando se libera el
petróleo y el gas de la roca estos
compuestos emergen con una fuerza enorme
como cuando abrimos una botella gitana
de cocacola o gaseosa
exactamente estamos hablando del
polémico fracking o fractura hidráulica
este es el motivo por el que vaca muerta
no se ha podido explotar hasta hace
relativamente muy poco
ahora bien llegados a este punto hay una
pregunta que estoy convencido a muchos o
rondaba por la cabeza de cuánto petróleo
y de cuánto gas estamos exactamente
hablando porque esa esa es la cuestión
clave realmente puede el yacimiento de
vaca muerta suponer un antes y un
después para la argentina pues atentos
gracias a vaca muerta producimos más de
3 por ciento más de gas que hace un año
desde el 2011 que no teníamos una
producción tan alta
oxígeno frente a la crisis
para continuar esta historia tenemos que
remontarnos hasta el año 2011 ese año
repsol una petrolera española anunció el
mayor descubrimiento de su historia
repsol ypf se anuncia el mayor
descubrimiento de petróleo de su
historia repsol ypf se calcula que
existen unos recursos de petróleo y gas
recuperables y equivalentes a 927
millones de barriles de petróleo pero
los amigos eso no era más que el
comienzo hoy se considera que como
mínimo vaca muerta es el segundo mayor
yacimiento de todo el mundo de gas no
convencional y el cuarto mayor de 6 oil
de hecho según las estimaciones de la
agencia de la energía de los eeuu
las reservas ojo explotables a día de
hoy de este yacimiento ascienden a 16
mil millones de barriles de petróleo y
308 trillones de pies cúbicos de gas
natural pero ahora bien cuanto suponen
realmente estas cantidades
[Música]
pues amigos para que os hagáis una idea
16 mil millones de barriles de petróleo
equivalente a dos veces las reservas de
petróleo convencional de países como
noruega o angola son casi 60 años del
consumo de petróleo que tiene argentinas
60 años
y en cuanto al gas natural el consumo de
argentina viene a ser aproximadamente de
un trillón de pies cúbicos es decir para
que nos entendamos tan sólo las reservas
explotables de vaca muerta 308 trillones
de pies cúbicos de gas natural equivalen
a casi 300 años del consumo de gas de la
argentina
[Música]
vamos que en vez de vaca muerta tendría
que llamarse vaca gorda porque hablamos
de una vaca cargada hasta reventar y no
precisamente de leche sino de petróleo y
gas
[Música]
todo esto significa que en poco tiempo
la argentina podría por un lado tener
una importante ventaja competitiva
disponer de energía barata y no hay nada
que le venga mejor a la industria que
poder disponer de energía barata por
otro lado el país también podría
hincharse a exportar gas natural no solo
a sus vecinos latinoamericanos sino
fundamentalmente al resto del mundo
especialmente a asia
y esto es interesante porque seguro que
la mayoría de vosotros al igual que
nosotros estáis preocupados por la
sostenibilidad y el medio ambiente
verdad
a quien no le gustaría que en poco
tiempo las energías renovables y otras
fuentes de energía menos contaminantes
tuvieran un papel protagonista sin
embargo hasta llegar a ese punto hay un
paso mucho más urgente que dar sustituir
el carbón en los procesos de producción
especialmente en los países emergentes
como china que aún genera el 70 por
ciento de su electricidad quemando
carbón
[Música]
con su enorme población y su gran
dependencia del carbón china es con
mucho el mayor contaminador del mundo es
responsable de más emisiones que los
eeuu y la unión europea combinados y es
que en esta misión tanto por coste como
por tecnología el gas natural funciona a
las mil maravillas y desde luego es
mucho más limpio que el petróleo y
muchísimo pero con muchísimo más que el
carbón así que incluso si hablamos en
términos de sostenibilidad vaca muerta
es una gran noticia pero un momento
llegados a este punto seguro que alguno
de vosotros que está pensando bueno si
tal vez y así eso en un futuro vaca
muerta igual le sirve de algo a la
argentina pues amigos no podéis estar
más equivocados no estamos hablando de
un futuro posible vaca o muerta ya está
teniendo consecuencias muy positivas
para la economía argentina hoy
[Música]
veréis la falta de inversión y el
declive de los viejos yacimientos
provocó que desde el año 2008 la
argentina haya tenido que importar una
enorme cantidad de caso natural y
petróleo lo que por supuesto supuso un
déficit mucho más alto en la balanza
comercial y una enorme salida de dólares
del país sin embargo ahora eso está
empezando a cambiar la producción de
crudo acumula 16 meses de crecimiento
interanual ininterrumpido el no
convencional que tuvo un aumento del 47%
ya representa un 18 por ciento de la
producción total hace 14 meses que
argentina no debe recurrir a las
importaciones de petróleo gustavo
lopetegui el secretario de energía de la
argentina y con el gas natural las tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo desde 2017
las importaciones netas se han reducido
más de un 50 por ciento nuestro gran
desafío es continuar aumentando la
producción para abastecer el mercado
interno y poder convertirnos en
exportadores de gas durante todos los
meses del año esto nos permitiría
converger a precios menores para el
mercado interno tanto para hogares como
para el sector industrial
gustavo lopetegui secretario de energía
de la argentina
evidentemente sin este cambio la crisis
que actualmente atraviesa argentina
hubiera sido aún peor mucho peor o lo
que es lo mismo vamos que si mauricio
macri no hubiera tenido a vaca muerta ya
no es que hubiera sacado unos malos
resultados es que no le habrían votado
ni en su casa y desde luego la situación
de argentina sin vaca muerta sería aún
mucho peor de lo que es hoy
[Aplausos]
el caso amigos es que si se logra poner
a trabajar este yacimiento a pleno
rendimiento tan solo el impacto en la
balanza exterior del país podría ser
enorme según carlos ormachea presidente
de tecpetrol una de las empresas que
está trabajando en ese sitio estaríamos
hablando de un impacto positivo de 30
mil millones de dólares cada año 20 mil
millones en exportaciones y otros 10 mil
millones de dólares que no saldrían del
país para comprar hidrocarburos y desde
luego todos esos dólares le vendrían muy
bien al país para superar sus
desequilibrios exteriores pero esto lo
que necesitamos sacudirnos y darnos
cuenta de todo lo que podemos ser
capaces de hacer entender ahora por qué
es tan importante de los rescates del fm
y pasaríamos al mega rescate de vaca
muerta sin embargo amigos esperar un
momento porque las cosas no son tan
sencillas atentos hemos desendeudado
definitivamente a la república
el salario más alto de toda
latinoamérica con un aumento de más de 2
mil por ciento la política siempre la
política una pregunta os acordáis del
descubrimiento de repsol en 2011 que os
hemos comentado antes pues amigos esa
gran noticia fue sin embargo el inicio
de muchos muchísimos problemas con tanto
dinero de por medio la entonces
presidenta de argentina cristina
fernández de kirchner tomó una polémica
decisión nacionalizar de forma forzosa
la empresa y pf la mayor petrolera
argentina que en aquel momento formaba
parte del grupo repsol de golpe y
porrazo mediante la expropiación el
gobierno argentino tomó el mando y las
cosas se pararon tras la nacionalización
no sólo comenzó un largo proceso
judicial que le ha terminado costando al
país mucho pero que muchísimo dinero
sino que la inversión internacional se
frenó en seco
y amigos el sector del petróleo es un
sector que requiere de inversiones
gigantes de miles y miles y miles de
millones de dólares al final el proyecto
se quedó prácticamente parado sin
embargo en 2015 con la llegada al poder
de mauricio macri el proyecto volvió a
cobrar vida y comenzó una enorme lluvia
de millones para poder explotar este
gran tesoro
pero aún hace falta mucho muchísimo más
permitir a los políticos argentinos que
vaca muerta se desarrolle lograr a
argentina sacar provecho de vaca muerta
dejadnos vuestras opiniones en los
comentarios y ya sabéis no olvidéis
suscribiros abisal político y si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante
hacernos saber dándole al botón de like
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]